ah wow man does it mean to move this
dick that's closer
or i'm gaming darn it she went before
thanksgiving
we didn't move the desk out you know i
just wanted the folks at home don't know
that
one of the nice things about this
program when you're guesting the show
you actually get
in your dressing room conan o'brien
stuff
yeah that's true they get this but you
know what i'm so lucky just coming on
this show
i'm not keeping this for myself ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
hey yeah
i just want to give something back to
the people
that was an inspired gesture i already
wore it too
that was you know i think i should give
something back to the people yes i do
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
andy come on andy handy
wow incoming
oh man andy
[Applause]
andy for those of you who weren't at
home who aren't fortunate enough to see
that
andy clocked the woman sitting inside
but you know she's still smiling oh like
i didn't want to get any closer i could
have stepped
on the back of their ticket you actually
nbc has no responsibility in case you're
injured by a foul that's right
[Laughter]
so pour the lava stage hands all right
how have you been how are you good good
feeling good you know thanksgivings here
thanksgiving coming coming up ready you
know one of the things i'm a little
upset about though what's that
well right now hey hey let's settle down
a bit
oh hey tony's jackets
it's just man man hey actually did you
see that
it fits that jacket fits beautifully
fabulous
it fits beautifully you know those pants
would look good on him
you know this isn't a cable show yet
sorry
let's leave these on right now you know
the one big problem your show is
is taping right now yes uh the leno show
is taping right now
right upstairs yes donahue is taping
right now the problem is there are no
elevators for those of us who work here
really i've been waiting 10 minutes to
get help i think look you folks paid
didn't pay anything to get in here
you ought to just walk your butts up
here next time all right
oh no you know what's too bad yeah you
know what you won the crowd over by
giving them something
and then now you piss them off but the
challenge is to get them back now
they're gonna want this watch
ah good night everybody
drive safely he can't i mean there are
more shows taping in this
in this place it's crazy it's insane
well it's just like around here i mean
with the you know the trees going up for
the big lighting and the tree is
actually right outside your uh your
guy's little studio that's right so
they're getting ready to put that up
funny story
uh i was walking they've got wooden
scaffolding all around it and i'm
getting ready across the street uh
yesterday and there's a couple standing
on the corner and the guy's looking up
and going
i don't know i guess you're getting
ready to uncrate it
this is the way it is can you imagine
the box that thing came in
wait now you say it now are you going to
be doing the uh thanksgiving day parade
well i don't hear
willard willard scott is is co-hosting
the parade with david couric
and i'm going tomorrow night
to do the news the local news from where
they start blowing the balloons up
which is up by central park west and
78th street
uh i didn't do it last year because
there was an unfortunate uh
incident i was walking along they were
supposed to blow up the shamu balloon
some guy
mistook me and oh no yeah
surgically removing a helium hose it
just wasn't
you know i mean it's you don't you don't
have no idea maybe you do andy but i
mean
uh
but you know oh now you're gonna have to
just give them money
how much you got on you wow this is a
tough crowd
stick around after the show you're gonna
get four hundred thousand dollars in a
small bill
and you know considering you didn't pay
to get in here this is a good deal our
crowd pays to get in oh
sorry yeah sorry i'm just i just want
the folks at home to be impressed
but no it's you know it's just the big
thanksgiving day thing and
i i try to basically watch it on
television that's the best place to
watch it
sitting at home sitting there and
watching willard put on funny hats with
katie you know that's that that's
safe at home you're safe nobody's
throwing chestnuts at you you know
it's good good for you what a nice nice
uh image of the holidays basically now
uh i understand that you
you brought a clip with you yes yeah
does this clip need any setting up
actually it does what you need to know
is there's a cold front coming in
okay okay all right well let's uh let's
take a look at al roker's clip
roll it please dana cold front pushing
through and with that cold front
high pressure builds in coldest air of
the season 20s north and west tonight
30s and 40s everywhere else that cool
air is going to stay on top of us for
the next 48 hours
thank you thank you
that was very that was very powerful and
that's over-the-air free television
very that was powerful stuff i enjoyed
it classic rock
her at his finest well i was hoping for
better
but it didn't work no no that's good
enough what about this hurricane i want
to get something important i want to get
some is it
hurricane gordon it's called gordon
what kind of name is gordon that's why
it was such a screwy hurricane
it was coordinating well the one before
was the next one that was supposed to be
fabio
really yes there's a hurricane fabio yes
there is but it doesn't do much it just
stays out in the ocean and flexes